Do you have any idea how you plan to
start taking action towards the ideas
you have for your business?
Let's start by breaking
down your mission and
vision statements into
a set of 12 month goals.
For your 12 month goals,
try to answer questions like.
How many customers do you want to have?
How much revenue do you hope to make?
And what metrics are you looking
at to help you get there?
There are plenty of other
questions you can ask.
And this really depends on the type of
impact you're hoping to have with your
business.
Here's a strategy you can
use to help get started.
Try thinking about a core objective
that's fundamental to the success
of your business.
For example,
maybe your app needs lots of users.
Can you imagine making any progress
at all and gaining these users?
How many do you think you could get?
Write that number down.
Now in what timeframe do you think
it would take to reach that goal?
Once you have that number,
you can adjust it relative to what
portion of the goal could be
achieved within the next year.
Let's look at an example of how
you might be able to use this
for your business.
I feel pretty confident that I
could get ten customers in a month.
So maybe 120 customers is
a good goal for my first year.
Or, if 5,000 customers in my first
five years seems reasonable,
then maybe I could reach a 1,000
customers by the end of year one.
Start where you're comfortable and
work from there.
Another idea you can try is to
look into similar businesses.
Seeing where they started, and
finding out how they were
able to grow over time.
And remember these goals can change.
The idea right now is to really just
get something to work from later on.
So take some time to think about
where you hope to be in one year, and
when you're ready write
out your 12 month goals.